oh my god i am so excited to speak with
you i
have had such appreciation and respect
for you for so many years same same uh
i've been watching you and your
beautiful fiance and beautiful daughter
and we'll get into in kanto in a minute
thank you and i was watching you at the
academy awards and you know the
emotionality is right there on the
surface and it is about family
but is it true
that you still live with your family
it's it's uh complicated uh
i love this tell us so
i'm a latino man
the end
it's
it's very simple you
do it's it's it's very simple you know
um
we believe in in family you know and and
when i when we came to the united states
back in 93 94 um you know the sacrifice
that my parents
you know had to bring us to america what
they gave up
uh just for us to be here so so you know
to answer your question why does my
family live so close aka in the same
property um
you know i i knew that i was going to
have children because that's what i
wanted in my life i wanted to be a
father and
so i i had an opportunity and i went for
it i bought this couple of acres in in
la and um as soon as i was finishing up
70 show i was like i don't know whenever
i'm gonna make this kind of money again
so i think i'm gonna i'm gonna buy
something that'll last me forever you
know i bought this property i knew i saw
my kids running around there when i was
26.
and then i had an opportunity to buy the
neighbor's house that only has like
trees and bushes in between mine and
that house
so when i bought that house i gave it to
my mom you know so my mom so my mom is
like
so my mom is
get the machete out and just buy that
property and knock that you know with
all due respect to the greenery
make way
because i also knew
that i think that i subliminally knew
that at some point when i had kids i
would have like a built-in babysitter
you know 100
and then for sure it became that my mom
has like chefs
you know in the dish you could walk
through the you know throw the little uh
uh revolving door in between our
properties she picks up the baby in a
tent she takes her god's breakfast and
lunch with her brings her back and it's
like it's pretty incredible to have that
and uh you know um yep so yeah i do have
my my family living in the same property
what did your fiancee
think when she was like oh well so
you're all living together
was she like i'm in i'm on board or was
she like oh wow that's not my life
experience she's what was her attitude
she's half she's half mexican so she was
half like okay i love it but then like
forever
um but but i i think it was uh you know
we were very uh intentional about
everything we we were doing when we when
we got together then we we knew we knew
that when we got together that a family
was a possibility and as soon as we
started doing the math they're like oh
mom next door absolutely like that and
now i have loved you obviously um as a
creator too in kanto
huge won the academy awards
thank you
congratulations
thank you when your beautiful daughter
um
watches
the film does she recognize your voice
because you play the father the
patriarch yeah she but she's so she's 14
months she recognizes the music now
she's just loving it um but you know
speaking of when you were it's what
triggered me was that
um i feel like i subliminally have been
making things and you know and creating
things in my career um and banking them
as an archive so when she's old enough
she arrives to uh you know to a well of
content that looks and sounds like her
and that also you know uh sees the
relativity of of the humanity of this
family that's timeless and then um but
yeah i just yeah i love it i'll wait
until she enjoys all the years of that
70s show too which was i never i'm gonna
delay
the lady
yeah when she's older but then there's
ncis your special agent nick torres
thank you
thank you
i know that you also have zorro in
development at disney plaza can you
believe it are you going to be able to
maintain all of this or i mean this is a
lot on your plate
it is a lot of my plate um but i'm up
for the you know i'm up for the
challenge i think is is um
you know you come to a point in your
life where you know we talk about these
mountain areas and i think zoro is one
of those right i love you with zorro so
much i can't even handle it get it okay
hurry hurry hurry hurry thank you thank
you
i'll tell you that this will be a zorro
for this generation and uh it'll be
incredibly thoughtful with with its
origin story and it'll be grounded in
authenticity well i trust it very much
in your hands
[Music]
you